>> HIS IMMEDIATE REACTION WAS TO
START TELLING ME ABOUT AN
INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED WITH HIS
SON WITH A BOATING ACCIDENT.
>> LET'S GO TO BREAKING NEWS.
NANCY PELOSI IS SPEAKING FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE THE AUDIO AND
VIDEO OF THE BODY CAM OF HER
HUSBAND'S ATTACK HAS BEEN
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
SO LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT SHE IS
SAYING AT THE CAPITOL RIGHT NOW.
>> GOD BLESS YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
IT IS WITH A GRATEFUL HEART AND
ON BEHALF OF MY ENTIRE FAMILY
THAT WE CONTINUE TO THANK PEOPLE
FOR ALL OF THEIR PRAYERS, THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO SEND US, ASKING
ABOUT THE PROGRESS MY HUSBAND IS
MAKING.
AND HE IS MAKING PROGRESS, BUT
IT WILL TAKE MORE TIME.
AS YOU KNOW TODAY, THERE WAS A
RELEASE OF SOME INFORMATION.
I HAVE NOT HEARD OF THE 911
CALL.
I HAVE NOT HEARD THE CONFESSION.
I HAVE NOT SEEN THE BREAK-IN,
AND I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
INTENTION OF SEEING THE DEADLY
ASSAULT ON MY HUSBAND'S LIFE.
I WON'T BE MAKING ANY MORE
STATEMENTS ABOUT THIS CASE, AS
IT PROCEEDS EXCEPT TO, AGAIN,
THANK PEOPLE AND INFORM THEM OF
PAUL'S PROGRESS.
BUT THAT WILL BE THE END OF WHAT
I WILL SAY ABOUT THE CASE.
THANK YOU.
>> HOW IS YOUR HUSBAND DOING?
>> OKAY.
THAT WAS VERY SHORT FROM NANCY
PELOSI, BUT SHE DID TAKE A
MOMENT AT THE CAPITOL THERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO, THE BODY
CAM VIDEO THAT WAS JUST RELEASED
FROM -- ABOUT HER HUSBAND'S
SHE SAID THAT SHE WILL NOT BE
COMMENTING ON THE CASE AS IT
PROCEEDS.
CNN CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MANU RAJU JOINS US
NOW.
SHE FELT IT IMPORTANT TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE AND MARK THIS
MOMENT?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
SHE WAS BEING ASKED BY REPORTERS
ABOUT THE VIDEO SINCE WE LEARNED
THAT IT WOULD BE RELEASED AS
SOON AS YESTERDAY, AND SHE
INDICATED SHE WASN'T SURE AT
THAT POINT IF SHE WAS GOING TO
SEE IT.
SHE PROBABLY WAS NOT GOING TO
WATCH THIS VIDEO, AND SHE WANTED
TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT SHE IS
NOT GOING TO WATCH THE VIDEO AND
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO COMMENT ANY
FURTHER ABOUT THIS SITUATION.
OBVIOUSLY ONE THAT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY TRAUMATIC FOR HER AND
HER HUSBAND.
SHE SAID THAT HERSELF, AND
KNOWING -- SHE SAID THAT ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT THINGS FOR
HER WAS KNOWING THE ATTACKER WAS
ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR HER THAT
DAY, AND THEN HE VICIOUSLY
ATTACKED HER HUSBAND WITH A
HAMMER AND WE SAW THAT VIDEO
RELEASED TODAY, SHOWING HOW THAT
ATTACK HAPPENED.
THE TWO WERE HOLDING A HAMMER.
THE POLICE, WHEN THEY ENTERED
THE SCENE, ASKED HIM TO DROP THE
HAMMER.
PAUL PELOSI DID.
THE ATTACKER HELD ONTO IT AND
ATTACKED HIM.
THAT OBVIOUSLY -- THAT EPISODE,
VERY TRAUMATIC FOR THE PELOSI
FAMILY, AND SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE -- MR. PELOSI HAS TRIED TO
RECOVER OVER THIS TIME PERIOD
HERE, BUT PELOSI MAKING CLEAR
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO SEE, SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO LISTEN TO THIS -- ANY OF
THOSE AUDIOS RELEASED OF THE 911
CALL, AND IS DONE COMMENTING ON
THIS EPISODE HERE, AND OF
COURSE, HER, AT THE TIME, THIS
HAPPENED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS WAS NOT -- SHE WAS NOT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AT THE TIME.
SHE WAS IN D.C. AT THE TIME.
CAPITOL POLICE WERE NOT ACTIVELY
MONITORING THE HOME OF THE
THEN-SPEAKER IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH IS WHY THIS ASSAILANT WAS
ABLE TO BREAK IN, ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY HE WAS ABLE TO BREAK
INTO THEIR HOME.
SO HERE WE'RE HEARING